[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm Linc this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are helping you guys out
in the business sector
oh well that's such an over promise we
should have talked about how we were
going to platform this can I mean I
think the honest answer is we asked you
to ask us questions about work in the
work workplace situations that we can
help breathe our perspective where
otherwise it may not need to be wedged
and we shouldn't promise that we're
going to help because I kind of focus
Ben when we do help will seem awesome
I know well yeah under-promise and
over-deliver but that's not even what I
mean what I'm saying is that's marriage
not work it's like a doctor giving it's
like a non doctor giving medical advice
I think that we should always claim
remus every single question and answer
episode with we are not experts do not
take any of our advice
what is that why how do you say this
what is like the correct like legal way
to say this no horses were harmed in the
making of this year biscuit that's
definitely true no animals period I
don't think well there might be an
insect under my foot right now gosh
why'd you have to make me think about
that who knows I mean you're not really
the type to to hit to the edge no no I I
know I feel like we we we've been
hedging do you know that we're horse is
also getting are we gonna go somewhere
with these workplace situations and
you're hedging because we're gonna be
wedging ourselves in and I'm just saying
that we may not turn out well if people
follow our advice I'm just saying that I
don't know what advice I'm giving but if
we try to platform ourselves as a
bastion of advice then people may be
disappointed because we're not remember
dr. Ruth you don't have to convince me
no well I I'm a women generally aware
but I don't know what happened to her
nothing happened to her I'm just saying
we're not her
remember let's let us forget the lest we
forget the lessons of dr. Ruth you know
was also is giving sex advice which we
haven't done yet I'm not saying we're
not going to it's all the way but that's
a category I mean I don't know maybe
2027 okay
but twenty twenty says so the category
was just workplace situations we got
some really good questions let me tell
you right now you guys we didn't even
give you that much time to respond to
this question and if you want I mean
there's so many good questions but if
you're not following us on on Twitter
and Facebook that's where we're putting
this stuff out so if you want to be part
of the responding to prompts then keep
an eye out over there rhett and Link on
Facebook and on Twitter that's what
we're doing it right rhett and Link
everywhere nowadays we're also mythical
in places for different types of stuff
so that's different that's something
that's about the mythical vibe right um
let's let's go with this one from Kyle
first off just because it's on the first
page I have a co-worker who sits next to
me and sings to himself at a moderate
volume nearly all day he only sings the
catchiest things that get stuck into
your head and it drives me mad stuck in
your head is what I don't want to make
Kyle's doing like a [ __ ]
oh oh yeah I didn't put a two in there
example everything is awesome so Kyle's
over there working and then he's got a
he's got a co-worker sitting next to him
[Music]
this person sits next to you Kyle
and uh man this is uh this is almost
unbelievable that this is happening and
you say it's moderate a moderate volume
case if you don't like that details
that's what is it everything is awesome
when you're living in your jeans I can't
remember yep when you get actually
something about dreams you're fly
fishing streams moderate volume nearly
all day now first of all this this seems
kind of crazy but I totally believable
because when you if you're really
susceptible to ear worms everybody's
susceptible but if you're really
susceptance um times you just find
yourself singing it like last night at
the dinner table with my family right
before dinner Lincoln had his laptop up
and for some reason he pulled up huddle
mostly ins had the laptop at the dinner
time no before we go to the table we're
like the kitchen counter and he pulls up
he thought it'd be funny he pulls out
the most annoying YouTube videos and
starts playing them like the Apple pen
pineapple pastilla he went when he like
pulled that back out of the vault and
then there's this other song that they
are obsessed with and it's hey you got
any grapes dad up he goes up to a
lemonade stand and keeps it's a duck
that keeps waddling up to a lemonade
stand and ordering grapes and it goes on
for way too long he's gonna donate his
like grapes grapes will kill a dog I'm
so dad right now I don't understand and
I'm so annoyed by it but then we get to
the dinner table and we're having a
legitimate conversation as a family and
then every few minutes even one of the
kids start singing it there got any
grapes and they say Miss Ellie a song to
me I could look at their face and tell
that they didn't even okay are we
burning the water Italy we're gonna
catch fire in here but don't don't block
the huh don't block the shots guys this
is the best thing that's ever happened
to ear biscuits for those of you who are
just listening not watching are we still
rolling
that's the most important thing so so
that the main thing that you need to
know if you're only listening to this is
this the Sun fell from the sky the dim
lighting has become really bright
because the it's the the lighting fell
right in the middle of the table knocked
over rets your biscuit jar onto his
phone which is kind of wet but it's okay
my water's fine
this is Kiko that was Jacob they're
trying to clean up and make sure that
like this place doesn't short out and
just burned down but somebody's got a
man the helm so I can't wait to watch it
back like I don't know if the shock on
her faces was covered by the by the fact
that that big the big ball came down
right in front of us it could have been
the end guys I mean what you're don't
listen the worst is over guys don't
panic it's cool everything is awesome
okay we're back we got the light back up
so we're getting back in here I'm still
wet and you know what I have a little
more information now
[Music]
oh I've heard this well I'm such a
ignorant Internet Taner and you guys
were probably screaming this if you're
not it's the duck song from it from old
March 23rd 2009 you know how many views
this thing yes let me guess the duck
song 2009 two hundred and seventy four
million views that's a crazy guess and
you're still low three hundred and
eighteen thousand eighteen million of
you 318,000 hey for a guess that's not
but can't even see that as 318 million
it's so crazy we've got a million thumbs
up 318 million views there's a sequel to
well yeah yeah France move on so my kids
just to finish that little anecdote that
has left us yeah that's is my thought as
we were I was talking to Christy and the
kids if it wasn't one it was another one
who was singing the song and I would
look at him and I could tell by the look
on their face they didn't know they were
singing the duck song it was just an ear
worm so your brain just starts playing I
could totally relate
I mean but what do you do about it
because even today we hi all we had we
had a song what you'll find out all the
GMM later we had a song that was in our
our heads all day that we were randomly
singing I I think I have a solution to
this now you could do the direct
approach but the direct honest approach
to say hey man you're annoying me with
your music don't do that that's no fun I
don't think it will work by the way well
here's what here's what I would do
okay you be the guy that's singing the
song to himself
okay go through the course I cook all
the times and I'll tell you what I would
do no no no sing everything is hot so I
sing a song I know because it makes
you'll find out in a sec oh you have to
sing the chorus of everything is awesome
[Music]
when you're living in my jeans
everything is awesome everything is good
and you know the team everything is
awesome and then I'm looking at you like
what happened to you well three-time the
guy starts singing sing louder than him
in a slightly different key and he will
stop
that's time you will stop I guarantee
you will embarrass yourself you will
lose friends but you will gain your
sanity back try it what you don't want
real time you're saying you'll lose him
as a friend or you'll lose others you
lose other friends because they'll be
like why is this doofus singing
everything is awesome dole out off-key
right now it doesn't matter it's worth
it you will get your sanity back and
lock eyes with the guy when you're doing
it yeah if it's a cubical situation you
you you peek over the top ha slow your
words a little bit everything your money
my team he will stop he will never do it
again that's the solution to that Kyle
try it and then report back the most
surprising part about that was how
easily you sang off-key it that's not an
easy thing to do on purpose I'm like a
wolf like owls before you ask another
question yeah let's take a short break
what yeah we know you want nuts not to
just took a long way trying to fix this
light well not I mean it's not really a
break it's a break to let you know about
something that you can add to your life
what's going on at mythical dot store
these days don't you want to know we've
got the cotton candy reading t-shirt
it's really cool
everything is awesome when you wherever
the cotton candy drannit t-shirt I got
to work on that he's like he's a cult
favorite guys everybody loves him
actually you know what the thing about
the thing I love about cotton candy
Randy is he so polarizing the most
polarizing we've heard this and I
absolutely love polarizing things that's
why some of you hate me and some of you
hate you because I'm polar rocking about
me let's just keep it off the air and I
absolutely love cotton candy Randy and I
love the fact that so many people love
him and I know you've said this and I
said if you hate
it wear it out of hate but you can also
find different things admit you don't
like talking about McCartan candy Randi
you just gotta say that with me talking
about cutting cane know how polar it I
Avanti you've already told them that me
talking about cotton candy Randi is
polarizing for you the whole thing you
said about polarizing you're saying it
like you've never said it but if you've
said it before
not everybody listens to every year
biscuit I'm saying it for the moon if
you want something else there's other
stuff at mythoclast or and if you want
to know when new stuff hits mythical dot
store sign up for our mythical
newsletter it's free it's intriguing
it's entertaining it gives you behind
the scenes of a recent issue our wives
contributed to the newsletter so that's
mythical monthly comm is that you sign
up for that I believe so
here's another question Hannibal this is
a doozy there are four you know what I
didn't want to say I'm not gonna say her
last name we're gonna beep that did we
say Kyle's last name no because we said
we wouldn't say those yep you did which
you give me a hard time about doing all
the time which is I said don't say their
full name you told me three times yeah
they should have told myself like well
I've marked it out yeah I should have
done that hannah blank there are four
student workers in my office
Hannah myself Olivia Katrina and Melissa
our boss refers to us as Heather Hannah
Kristina and Melanie respectively we've
corrected her many times that she is not
calling any of us by the proper names
but she has yet to change to using our
real names how do we get our real names
back now asterisks on Hannah and that is
when she uses Hannah
despite being my name she is always
asking for Olivia Hannah never actually
refers to me so she's got one name out
of four right but he's referring to the
wrong person
she's four names I had to draw a little
diagram to understand this so her the
boss calls Hannah Heather the boss calls
Olivia Hannah yep
the boss calls Katrina Christina that's
okay that one's the only one that makes
sense
and the boss calls Melissa Melanie okay
she's been corrected but many times many
times yeah and she keeps going back well
this is just a this is a power bit I
think oh I think it's but it's someone
who gets people's names wrong all the
time yeah it's a power play for me it's
not a power play you but you don't think
I'm stupid
no you don't do this I made sure no no
you don't do that well I will say today
nothing have we talked about this
no it just happened what do you mean a
milk no no no the Johnny Johnny thing
that no no we've been talking about it I
thought we talked about it in a good
mythical more and we just talked about
it with a person an hour okay well we
met somebody the other day and they said
they introduced themselves as Johnny and
it was for me it was really simply clear
they said Johnny a lynx head back to the
guy Johnny you made up a name that
doesn't exist and then it was really
funny to me and then an hour ago well
two hours ago we met a guy named Chris
he introduced himself is Chris and link
said crews so he automatically assumes
these names that are like very unique
but the two most common names on earth a
Johnny and Chris uhyou assume we're jadi
and Cruz which is similar but different
but as soon as you were corrected you
stopped
you didn't yeah I'm not a I'm not a jerk
so this has been pointed out I don't
think to this person this is it's weird
I mean yeah it is a working theory of
power but the boss could be could be
throwing the power around here it's like
I don't have to I know that's your name
but it's like to me it's akin to the
power play when you Cal some you give
somebody a nickname like and unless
you're like a recreation grade school
soccer coach you just can't go around
giving people nicknames it's you know I
would have thought you would be a
nickname er and I think I've been very
tempted by it and I searched my own
heart and I realized that it's it's like
looking down my nose at somebody like
Who am I I don't have the right
to change somebody's name or to order to
decide how it's pronounced or anything
like that you know I do agree that that
in those instances like when you give
somebody like a pet name that [ __ ]
that's a power place of power to them so
I don't know if that's happened this
year these are these are more alter egos
but this this is not this is it
this is getting somebody's name wrong I
to me if you've tried to correct her
multiple times if you believe you're
saying if we believe the best about the
boss if we believe the best about the
boss which we will choose to do we'll
choose to be mythical and do that nice I
think that this is an opportunity for
alter egos you guys you may be Hannah
Olivia Katrina and Melissa at home but
at work you're Heather Hannah Kristina
and Melanie you're super it's like
you're super alter egos you guys can
drink I would dude if I would you know
different be left-handed at work and you
can you do that it's mostly follows a
lot of handwriting can you be other
handed or like I don't know anything
that involves like a lot of dexterity
just be a different batter
wouldn't you love to say well I'm linked
at home but um Charles at work I mean
wouldn't you love to be able to do that
I think this is an opportunity for
somebody it would be it opens up a world
of possibility it's kind of like when
you go to a new school and you're like I
can be somebody new when you move a lot
of kids do that or it's like when Peter
Dinklage he used to be called chip your
neighbor and he was called chip four and
then one day he shows up at school and
he's like call me Peter and we all did
we all did took a while for me yeah cuz
you don't have calling him chip and then
the end account so okay so you know what
Hannah you need to stop you need to see
this as a blessing you see this as an
opportunity I love that yeah and when
your friend is confusing because one of
your friends is known as you you know
and I was talking to Olivia just then
yeah by the way right that's the
confusing part now you got two questions
that I think can be addressed together
although having read them I do believe
that they're at least my opinion there's
a different tack for each one of these
you want to read them both though sure
James
jiya he thought I was gonna say
something else after his but James that
just isn't his name says my officemate
often comes back from lunch and has
eaten so aggressively that she has to
use a flosser to dislodge the whole
chicken she has just eaten a flaw sir
yeah is that a is that a is that a Job
Description
right like somebody comes in a utensil
and this is a place where they have a
flaw sir makes me want to clean my teeth
right now I'm like searching then spends
20 minutes sucking said bird carcass
parts out of her teeth what do I do
and let's couple this with the question
from Melissa oMG I have a co-worker
across from me who eats unshelled
sunflower seeds all day crunch snap spit
crunch snap spit all day
what are they spitting if they're
already on shell I think
well my unshelled like they haven't been
had the shell removed oh that's the use
of that term us in this context all day
then add tap tap tap of the paper cup he
spits the seeds into so we've got two
annoying office mates coworker who sits
across in an office mate well the first
person James who has to endure the the
sucking of the bird carcass for 20
minutes at least you don't have to
endure the tap tap tapping that melissa
has to endure all day so James are just
trying to put your ears in perspective
in it you can leave for that window of
time you have pinpointed the problem
that was exactly what I was thinking
oh yeah I was thinking that for the
flosser you take a walk this is your
break time when when avoidance she comes
back and she breaks out the floss that
is your cue for a short break 20 minutes
20 minutes a 20 minute walk around the
building take an important phone call
this is an opportunity now Melissa
you're turning these into opportunities
Melissa on the other hand this is an
incessant crunch snap spit crunch snap
spit all day and my advice here I don't
know if it's possible I don't know if
I'm would be capable of this but I
believe you have to
learn to love it no yeah I disagree i
but I disagree but I think it can be
done I think you can learn to love
something I think the power of your mind
there are there are people who have done
deep meditative practices and they have
taken even pains that their body is
experiencing and they found a way to
focus in on them and actually to begin
to begin to gain pleasure from them and
now I don't think I could do it but I
read a book where somebody did it and
I'm thinking that maybe Melissa can take
a chance and see if she can learn to
love snaps what spit crunch snap spit
crunch snap spit whatever it is take a
chance on love Veen but what are you
this spits now you don't think you can
be learn to be loved I don't know you
kind of guilted me into agreeing with
you because it seems so metaphysically
higher plane you're gonna tell the guy
don't eat the thing you love I think
again in the spirit of believing the
best about someone you got to make sure
that you don't build up so much
animosity that it explodes in other ways
at work like you you don't want to be a
pressure cooker towards towards your
office mate who again believing the best
in this instance would be you know he
doesn't know it he doesn't know that
he's tapping he doesn't know that that
this is audible to anybody else or she
know if they mentioned I know it's a man
he spits the seeds into but then I don't
know I do think this is delicately and
almost apologetically approached and say
I know how much you love sunflower seeds
trust me but this is the opening salvo I
just wanted to say it the in its it
penetrates my ear hole so hard don't use
those for maybe rephrased I don't I
won't say penetrate or I didn't you can
think about it at it I agree with you
Rhett let's move
Kate well I wanted we're trying to find
be so confrontational right well being
confrontational there's got you know I
think that's something you would have to
talk about an office mate that implies I
picture two people in one office so this
is like an arranged marriage like I had
an office mate and I just I had to
become friends with him I haven't
learned to love him I learned to love
him but also learn to to be honest about
the things that weren't working because
you know what it goes both ways
and you're opening the door and you
could that could be part of it opening
salvo is I know how much you love
sunflower seeds trust me but it's it it
makes it difficult for me to concentrate
you do my job I said I said I finished
he could work and then by the end you're
saying and I'm sure there's things that
I do that might make it difficult for
you to your job and I want to open the
door for you to tell me those things
it's take place what if you started with
that what if you said hey Darryl
whatever his name is
is there anything about me that annoys
you like what if what if what have you
started with that question okay let's go
with that okay then Dale's like no
you're great and then what and then I
think you would naturally sell is there
anything about me welcome bill had you
asked no but let's say I'm yeah but
let's say that doesn't happen
listen so let's go through it then you
learn a little bit start over hey Darryl
something I've been meaning to ask you
you know we're office mates yeah and we
share this space yeah sometimes when
people share a space with each other
there's little quirks and stuff that can
get on each other's nerves and I'm
trying to be more conscious of that so
serious question is there anything about
me that annoys you no and that's it
no that's the end of the conversation
okay cool
what I'm gonna learn to love the fact
that you annoy me with your sunflower
seed spitting it's an internal
conversation you can't say that out you
can't trap somebody but then you can I
think there's a good way to do that
I think yeah you know you'll figure it
out Melissa Kate sorry we can be more
helpful
Kate asks how do you deal with a
ravenous co-worker who snoops around
after everyone has left and steals
everyone's snacks and candy from all of
the cubicles hashtag air biscuit arias
now if you're if you're not familiar
with cubicle culture as I am this may
come as a surprise to you that many cube
dwellers have a little a little stash of
candy or treats that they put in a bowl
like a dish like that you would normally
see on like a great-grandparents coffee
table yeah so that it is it's a really
smart thing because when someone comes
to your cube to have like a work
conversation they get a little reward to
have a billion it's like Oh whenever I
go see Darryl you know I get a few
sunflower seeds that's not the best you
know you all something individually
wrapped one of those strawberries that
has the gushy strawberry Center and Oleg
wrapped and looks like a yes you never
buy that but somehow someone has it Tina
Tina has had them there from 1984 ever
seen one of those have you ever seen a
store now for purchase no I don't
believe they're available for purchase
they're just I and you I've eaten them I
mean whenever I'm presented with one I
would lead any time I anything any time
the candy is wrapped like of the fruit
that it represents I eat it I've never
said no to that can't think of another
example but I agree with you yeah and so
that's a good idea just that's just
unsolicited advice for cubicle dwellers
treats treats somebody's going around
and stealing them and first of all this
would just be something cool to catch on
camera yeah this is definitely a hidden
camera situation but then if you're
gonna set up the hidden camera to catch
them you might as well go one step
further it plant a little no tea no tea
oh you're saying poison but yeah that is
what it sounded like
I
met like a spicy can't a spicy
strawberry candy rats don't poison do
not again all of our advice has to be
taken with a grain of salt done this
house is gonna hit me and I was just
asking the question I wasn't suggesting
that you should poison it I was saying
not treat a hot treat
take the strawberry unwrapped it nasty
but I was saying put something inject
something nasty turd is that going too
far or spicy
you could die eating it but but then
they're gonna leave but then at least
you'll know yeah you kind of want it if
when you play a prank on somebody you
want to be able to see them eat it I
don't think that when she's stealing it
she's eating it right there like I put
like a squirrel you got to put cameras
and everybody's cubicle this is all
worth it hey know after night one when
they steal the good candy you know who
it is
night to you put the put the putting a
tracker on the candy she swallowed the
tracker you know wherever she's going at
all times in what happens as you follow
the tracker on your computer to a
certain address and then you look up
that address and tie it to the co-worker
and you know who it is I'm
second-guessing the whole hidden-camera
thing in general because I think you
might get fired for that there's like a
privacy breach in that but well I think
seriously I mean it may be like a hunt
one of those hunter motion operated
cameras it just takes a photo of the
candy like a cougar yeah just set that
up so you get the Cougar that's it that
might not get this is all taking this is
taking too many resources and too much
time to set up trackers and that's what
people rubycles live for man oh you're
right you thought you could meet you
know I'm sitting in my cubicle back at
IBM days and I'm just looking for
something to live and breathe for well I
think you can start a movement though if
this is something I mean I want to catch
maybe a snare like the context here is
that this person is stealing everyone's
snacks and candy so if Kate knows that
this person is stealing everyone's
snacks and candy that means that there
has been talking amongst multiple people
you've got the innings of a movement
well first of all at this uprising if
it's everybody's candy then it's easy to
find out who did it it's the one cubicle
that still has candy so the price to it
if I don't have these be their own candy
they don't have their own key
they wouldn't be stealing I think that
you this might be a mass email like a
like a company email situation this may
graduate to that because it's
technically theft you know to whom it
may concern who is stealing all of our
candy who is this it this seems
passive-aggressive has come from yes
these come from the boss or an employee
employee is passive-aggressive BA and an
overreaching I think it comes from a
movement I think it goes from oh so like
a listservs it's it's a petition
everyone signs it we are a part of the
candy Union it's we the candy Union all
believed in agree that it is wrong and
morally apprehensible to sneak around
apprehensible steal yeah it makes me
nervous
steal my candies steal all our candies
so something we living in that you got
to lock up your candy every night right
now here's a question from someone I am
going to say his last name because I
love the way his last name sounds and
we've already said I've said it before
Napua
Bua Bua who asked another question now
we're not always going to answer your
questions just because your last name is
puah but you had a good one I know
you've discussed it in the book of
mythicality which I own and love hot tip
if you if you want a question read on
your biscuits include a plug for our
merch within the question who knows all
but how do you know when it's time to
leave the nine-to-five job to pursue
that something else that you're also
passionate about this is a good question
and one I think a lot of people are
probably wondering if I know many of you
right now or listening to this while in
the midst of doing something that you'd
rather not be doing it doesn't connect
with the deepest most inner you it may
not utilize your highest and most
refined skills and it may not reflect
your where you want to go in life but
first let us say that we are here for
you we're glad to be a part of taking
the edge of a sharp environment that you
find yourself in and you may not be able
to make a responsible decision to get
out of at this point that was I was like
my that was my comforting voice like
comforting kind of pick you up and it's
not gonna change overnight but maybe the
advice we're about to give can help you
in the long run I have some thoughts you
want to get you I mean you want to go
first
or I mean I gotta skip to it I think
anything as you start to pinpoint where
your passions lie find ways to invest
some time and energy and resources that
maybe money into developing that skill
develop or gaining experience there or
just starting to channel your passion
into something outside of work hours
that I mean so it's gonna require some
sacrifice I think you got it you it may
not be it most likely will not be
responsible for you just quit your 9 to
5 and then try to start something up you
you know we were very practical and we
can get into that but I think that's
that's where my advice is gonna land and
we can go into some of our experience if
you want to well I was good I mean I was
gonna basically say the same thing that
you you find a way you don't quit when
you you don't jump ship when you don't
have another ship to jump into mm-hmm I
think you've got to build a framework
that there is a practical maybe build a
rowboat and rosco the analogy and a
responsible a rowboat or a lifeboat of
some kind so that there so that you and
especially and obviously it depends on
what circumstance of life you're in if
you're married with children if you're
the breadwinner of the home or whatever
you that you which was the case with us
you have a special responsibility to
your family and so you can't just jump
ship and be like I'm going to find
myself and find what I'm passionate
about and then meanwhile you're all
going to starve you don't want to do
anything like that
if you're single and you can support
yourself and you don't have a lot of
expenses you could possibly quit but I
think that having something that you've
actually invested your time into and
there's some sort of practical path
towards a career because so speaking
from our own experience before we were
doing what we do
now we would get together once a week at
night to do comedy and sometimes that
was writing a song and but we were
constantly working on what is we just
what we were passionate about we had no
idea that it would ever be a career we
had no idea that we would ever the
things would get to this point we had
there was no career path but there was
just this very very small seed of an
idea that we just put ourselves into we
scheduled this regularly this regular
thing once a week and that became the
seed that grew into what this has become
just because we just said all right we
don't want to stop doing this steady job
but we want to try something else at
least a little bit that you gotta at
least have that yeah I mean anything if
your passions aren't being employed by
your employer then you got it I mean you
should you if you're passionate enough
about it you're gonna be willing to
sacrifice some of your some of your
extra time to invest in that on the side
and if if you're also good at it and
opportunity aligns then I think you'll
be ready to jump in something you know
when when the when there's more of an
opportunity or when that rowboat gets
built and it's got some oars and you can
you have a destination you can start
paddling towards you complete the
analogy page asks I work in retail and
I'm always bored any tips to pass the
time now page isn't saying that she
wants to jump ship and get out of retail
maybe maybe there's all probability in
retail and maybe it's just where she's
at for the time being that it gets
boring at times I've walked into retail
situations and I've boy I don't even I'm
not I'm just there as a customer and it
drains me I like I'll leave is floppy as
a ziploc bag full of water you know how
sometimes you have water is a ziploc bag
full of ice ice melts it melts like
man's nothing more flaccid than a
ziplock bag full of water did you have
to use that
that's how I leave clothing stores like
if I never went and another one in my
life
it's like from the moment I could be as
I could be the most vital human and it's
just like it's just it just sucks the
turgid and is right out of me it's just
so draining I can't imagine working
there well do you have it help page I
just I mean sorry sorry you really
really got you've laid the groundwork
for a great answer here yeah
I'm just feeling or pain sometimes
that's all you need someone to give you
a verbal ha just to be sympathetic
first of all neither of us have any
retail experience we this is not a job
that we ever did I don't think that
either of us would have been good at it
but I think you've got to get somewhat
creative I don't know what kind of
retail you're in but you'll never yeah
because you have to stay engaged and do
good at the job so that you can move
beyond it but if you saw it if this
Fester's then you're gonna get fired and
it's not gonna lead to any other
opportunities so I see where you're
going with this something that's like
well and something related to the job
cuz it keeps you going because because
but I don't think you can do which I
think a lot of people do is if you get
disengaged with your job and you replace
it with engagement and something that is
tertiary that isn't related to your job
mm-hmm you're you're on your way out
so in other words yeah if you do what I
did in the waning years of my
engineering career and you just go
online and learn about ultralight
airplanes and crow hunting and etc
you're not long for this engineering
world and so that means don't just
consume yourself with social media or
just gossiping about other co-workers or
just wasting time wasting the company's
time I'm not saying you're doing that
page I'm just saying that that can be a
temptation in an environment like making
paper airplanes with the printer paper
yeah I think you got it affecting your
design and throwing and exactly I think
we're talking things like let's just say
you
work in a clothing store read retail
retail clothing oh I thought retail was
clothing uh yeah it could be like you
know it could be vignettes or Pottery
Barn
- that would be a retail wouldn't it
sure but probably clothing that drains
me too okay anything that drains me like
it's already the only non clothing
retail I could think of was Pottery Barn
like I dug so deep and that's what
happened
Pottery Barn haven't been in a Pottery
Barn in a long time
sure it's great now the like folding
folding t-shirts I'm thinking about this
because I was recently in a retail store
and I saw a girl using this t-shirt
folder it's like a flat plastic thing
and now she was using the t-shirt folder
I was like that's neat and yeah we need
for a little bit but if she was like I'm
gonna do a new way to fold the t-shirt
I'm going to perfect the one handed
thing and then you start doing it and
you get really good at the one hand a
t-shirt folding and next thing you know
you've got a crowd oh it's like busking
next thing you know you got people
showing up watch the one arm she's got
to watch the two arm girl fold the
t-shirts with one arm and next thing you
know you got a line of people who
they're coming they're waiting in this
line I finally get up here and she's got
two hours I've heard wrong and she's
folding and then you get when you can do
to your look cheese folding to t-shirts
excess excess extra small on this hand
and extra large on this hand and I don't
know how she does it and next thing you
know people are buying no shirt left and
right you're working your way up to
manager the shirt says this shirt was
folded by the one-armed t-shirt well
then one day no one did it was and then
smaller it says and unfolded by me hey
yeah yeah and then one day you're
sitting in in the top of the skyscraper
with your glass office looking out over
the New York City skyline because you
are these Oh of this place and you know
what oh and you have
a little plaque over there tune the wolf
is back him people in a reminisce the
people reminisce and they're like you
see her you see her she's on the top of
this company she's at the top of the
world you know how she started let me
tell you a little story about folding
t-shirts with one hand that's how
legends get started page I would
recommend just hiding in the middle of
the the clothing rack you're jumping out
and scaring that's that's the shortcut
that could also work you could work your
way up to the top doing that nat pool
just say his name in between and every
once in a while yeah Lucy I work at an
elementary school how do I get my fifth
graders to think I'm cool this is easy
Lucy Fridays are gmm day Cody asks what
do when a crappy coworker gets more
recognition than you the one who really
deserves Cody Tony's got strong opinions
about himself he left out the word you
too what what D what what do what do I
do what to do what to do when a crappy
coworker gets more recognition than you
the one who really deserves it Cody I
would challenge you here if you believe
that you are less crappy of a worker
than the more recognized co-worker I
don't know your situation you could be
right
but I would challenge you to just try to
put an objective lens on on on the
situation and and look inward maybe
maybe there is something that's crappier
about your work than you know about or
maybe there's an aspect maybe there's a
there's another criteria that you are
not using to judge your work or your
crappy co-workers work that someone else
like your boss is seen that could that
could Mayberry well be a lot I think a
lot of us have a tendency to get bitter
with other people being recognized or
being compared
people are just not not seeing in
someone else what someone else does and
it's because you have a limited criteria
of what success is and for example
someone and I think this could this
could be me and many instances looks at
on paper like results an efficiency
results quality measurable things and
compare myself to someone else and say
the numbers don't lie
I I am out performing this person but
there's it there could very well be it
could very well be that that that other
person is more likeable oh the
indomitable I'm just giving an example I
think it's never underestimate the power
of being likable you could say it's
being nice or that it's being you know
when you work with people be somebody
worth working with and I you know I
think you could that easily like that
that could slip into being like some
sort of political I'm going to I'm gonna
make I'm gonna make somebody believe I'm
gonna buck kiss or I'm gonna make
somebody believe I'm great or I think
they're great and start playing games
I'm not suggesting that but I'm just
saying as one example and it could be
anything that you're it could be
different things that you that you're
missing as one of them never
underestimate being a co-worker worth
working for or working with or you know
what I'm saying
well I yes I do and I would say that as
a boss as bosses I would say that in the
instances in you know the past years of
being a boss hmm when we evaluated
someone's performance
there's you've got you've sort of got
two things right you've got your
performance and then you've got those
those intangible things like you're
calling it likeability
you know I think well I again I'm just
giving that as one example yeah yeah
yeah there's some other things but in
like that or not that are not as
measurable and likeability is it doesn't
mean it's like oh he's cool or whatever
it also means like plays well with
others works well has a positive
attitude yeah there's lots of things
that contribute to it and I would
definitely say that our evaluation of
people's performance has often been
influenced by well you know someone so
is struggling in this role but man he's
got a great attitude he really brings a
great his attitude sort of lights up the
room he's great to work with thank you
yeah I'm talking about linking suck he's
really suffering and is struggling in
his role here as co-host but he's a real
likable guy yeah yeah we keep him around
but when you've got the but nine times
out of ten or ten times out of ten if
someone is struggling in their
performance and they also happen to be
difficult to work with or it's just
something else that just makes them not
likeable that is something that do they
do have control over then it makes it
very difficult for us to have a positive
evaluation of them well and but to get
back to what Kody saying cuz this that
may not be the case with you Kody I do
think to echo the last thing you were
saying what we're encouraging you to
focus on the things that you can control
and you can't control how another
co-worker is perceived if you try that
could be very dangerous
it could be Savion to get into that so
focus on yourself and how in you know
what maybe you want to ask for feedback
from your superior without drawing a
direct comparison to anyone else when
you go to that person just ask you for
excuse me asking for honest feedback
yeah and I wouldn't mention anybody else
his name no Catherine asks what do you
do when a co-worker thinks they're
hilarious
but they aren't it seems so bad not to
laugh at all but their humor is that bad
oh this is tough yeah when somebody
thinks they're funny and it's like you
know maybe you you like him as a person
they're honestly trying dude man there
was a guy back in the IBM days we called
him baron the baron was that his name it
was his last name oh he would come
around and he always was yucking it up
with the jokes and they were always like
painfully they were just cringy and it
was the type of thing that like he would
put you on the spot I wish I mean it so
many years ago I don't have an example
but it was he kind of had this Michael
Scott from the office that was his name
yeah kind of vibe that's like he you
know he's in zero self awareness and
it's not like he'd be telling a joke to
a group he'd be telling a joke to you
and he's looking right at you and it's
like now it's time for you to laugh and
you're like huh yeah courtesy to have
and then that's that just that Stokes
the fire the courtesy but but it you
it's it's cold-hearted to just stare
right into his soul and just like be
flat-faced but you know you're pretty
good at that cuz a lot of people might
think that I would be the one that would
do the stone-faced and you do the
courtesy laugh but you know just as well
I can be cold that you're you can be
your I've seen this in my 30 plus years
of friendship with you yeah that you
have a tendency when somebody does that
in a maybe you didn't do it at IBM but
many times me and you have been talking
to someone and they said something
that's not funny
and I look at you and I can tell he's
not going to respond to this and your
stone-faced
and I'm like if I do this this is gonna
get so awkward so I'm just like hahaha
and you know why I do a courtesy laugh
all I do all that I've gotten is such a
habit of doing courtesy laugh cuz I'm a
people pleaser yeah but also because I'm
always with you and I hope you're not
gonna do it and I got a double out and I
have to do it you got to double up and
that's good on you because I'm not proud
of I think the reason why I can be I'm
stone-faced
is because I'm more concerned about what
other people
or observing this think about me than I
am about what he thinks about me because
if I if I laugh if I don't laugh it's
like oh he might think I'm a jerk but if
I do laugh everyone else thinks I'm a
chump who has no real sense of humor
dank link actually thinks that guy's
funny but you also know I'm gonna laugh
I think yes I think if I work out there
you probably laugh that's why I keep you
around the courtesy laugh fell back on
you you'd probably do it even though
your performance is par or subpar I keep
you around I'm so likeable for that
reason cuz you're very yeah well I need
you in that sense but but but the
question is how do I get somebody to
stop say here's what I think I think you
got to do the stone face no I think
there's a I this is what I think it is I
think there's a way to graciously say
something like this here's an example I
don't know what you would call it but
say Baron and you have a you have a
refined sense of humor you know it's
just kind of like that's not a little
sarcastic but I didn't mean it that way
it's more like trying to find the beauty
in the fact this guy his sense of humor
is not funny
you mean to say something as opposed to
laugh say something to him just kind of
like call him out on the fact that like
I didn't find that funny
but I really enjoy the fact that you
said it anyway yeah but what if that
pretty mean is that leads to not getting
anywhere well I don't know I'm not
trying to do this I'm gonna give similar
I guess mics I I have had experience
with this guy that like once he knew
that I didn't I didn't I still really
liked him and nothing I just said it all
sounded like a jerk but I don't know how
but I did succeed with Baron he knew
that I didn't think he was that funny oh
so it worked but I thought that he was
funny because he always tried to be
funny so we were friends is like I love
you man but I don't get your jokes also
you actually said that yeah eventually
well that's that not that worked because
typically if it worked for you this do
be what typical
the type of people that do that they had
their like there's a sweetness to them
that they're likable people in general
it's not like the boss in office space
right that guy deserves no mercy so if
they're like barren this guy who's like
super sweet guy who just doesn't he just
can't for the life of him make a funny
joke but he can't for the life of him
stop trying you gotta love him for it
yeah well III don't have any advice here
because I don't think I get it I would
be able to apply my advice because
stone-faced
I would yeah I'm just I'm a courtesy
laugh or you're always gonna get a laugh
from me but although you could probably
tell that it's fake definitely spicy 110
no name that's just it spicy 110
suggestions on separating home and work
when you work at home and don't have the
space for physical separation now one of
the things that we've always said we've
always valued face yeah so even before
we even had any idea what this Brett and
Link business was gonna be we had an
office it was a free office we used the
basement of my father-in-law's
one of my father-in-law's dental offices
I like the admin headquarters for his
general dental practices and it was just
like storage area that was really if you
ever watched the old school rhettandlink
a store some of the stuff on our channel
way back in the day that was that space
in Lillington and we always valued this
I mean you know both married with
children before we started doing this
job so we really needed to find a way to
get out now I realize your question is
that if you don't have space for a
physical separation you're giving them a
verbal hug you're feeling their pain
yeah you don't feel like you could do it
because it was good we've always just
said that I I know the way that we work
you know and I think for different
reasons for me I'm so easily distracted
and four-link you it's not that you're
distracted is that you are kind of
driven
crazy bye frustrated you're like more
frustrated by not being able to get into
a quiet space and for me if I'm in that
space I'm gonna get drawn in I'm angered
by it you're enticed by right but for
both of us
you know not being able to get away is a
huge problem yeah but let's just let's
try to answer the question in a way that
so I mean I would say first of all if
there is any way to have some sort of
shared workspace because there are very
affordable like shared workspaces now
there's all these like I don't even know
the name of it but basically you can you
can get like I know these work share
deals where you there's basically a desk
somewhere there there are affordable
options for people like a coffee shop is
very affordable well I don't know what
kind of work you're in anybody got to me
I've got to be on the phone yeah I'm
kind of assuming that like you got you
can't go two coffees you need something
that's not out in public so I might say
the library park bench types if you want
that separation the easiest way to
create it is to create physical
separation and try to find a way to
create physical separation if you cannot
find it in your home but let's just
assume you can't do that you can't
afford that there are no realistic
options for separation what do you do
closet closet push all the clothes the
one into your closet you get in the
other end close the door I'm imagining
there's kids running around you might
want to never know you're in there but
that's still physical separation there's
no space for physical separation you're
saying fine space you don't think
there's space find the space yeah I'm
saying let's just assume there is no
space this is a yurt let's say this is a
closet lizard okay okay at this point I
think you've got to have some sort of
physical indicator on your body that
indicates work time like a bucket on
your head it could be a helmet a helmet
is not a work hat I got my work cut on
you know I got more work glasses on I
got my work shirt on and it puts it what
it does is it puts you in a frame of
mine that I'm working now and it puts
the other individual
who may be in your space with you
they're like Oh
mama's got a bucket on her head she's
working so it can't be a literal bucket
but we're saying a hat helmet hat
apparel awesome glasses a wig the work
wig we could sell that mythical dodge
story the wig for the working person and
if you just put it on you know my
working business
daddy's daddy's on a roll he's got his
work wig on what would it look like it
would be like a it would be like a sharp
like a really like a professional it cut
down you could never find multiple
models for whatever gets big I think
it's some of them are twelve of them
there's curly curl out of curls and the
hair on the sides comes down and then it
curtain it goes down over the ears and
then it goes a bit forward to serve like
blinders on a corn horse the work wig
for the man a woman who wants to work
like a horse it also has a feed bag
right because you don't have to get up
and probably while we're at it we'll
attach one of those to drink stadium
pals that you just it's like the
external catheter and you just pee right
into a bag you don't have to get up you
got a helmet on you've got the trough to
eat and you've got right you got a
catheter somebody sketch this up so that
we can patent it work wig the work wig
would complete with Hilton feed bag and
peeps ounces pression sound suppression
blinders pee bag optional pee bag is
optional poop bag we don't have one of
those
we don't have one you got to take a crap
you got to go to the bathroom you need a
break anyway
we did not help it all on that one a lot
of these I feel like we're helping a lot
you want to do you want to end on a good
one you don't think that was a good one
to work wig sounds were quick document
minute let's end on a high note
Burt a co-worker with a nose whistle is
that an instrument - mission might as
well be sitting next to a foghorn
oh girl corn is low her nose whistle is
like if your nose is built in a weird
way and you
start if you're in it if you're working
and you're really deep into work you
almost get into like a meditative state
with like those long breaths it's a
higher pitch it's tough to emulate
unless you've actually got him you
didn't butcher that's creating this yeah
like if it's a booger it wouldn't happen
every day
this must be I know no you could have
you could well it could be a deviated
septum
it must be anatomical yeah an
anatomically and it's gendered Foghorn
like nose whistle nose whistle this is a
problem but I bet it only happens when
you get into that work state where it's
like this slow breathing
you think noise cancelling headphones
would help because know I love people
have have misconceptions about noise
cancelling headphones I think that they
can't say cancel everything but really
they just isolate certain frequencies
that are like monotonous in the
background and then they take those out
that's why I like it gets rid of like
the yeah if you can hear the person
talking to you on a plane if you were
like the quiet comforts in in in this
Bert you would actually hear much more
of just knows well I'm sincerely asking
the question is a nose whistle sustained
enough o to be recognized as a frequency
that can be chopped out chopped out
because the other thing you could do
this is a this is really this is not
great
it's a great solution so first we're
saying Bert trying try to get a pair of
$300 headphones and then take them back
if they don't get rid of the nose
whistle but another this could
potentially work right so you get a
laptop computer you get an an audio
editing software I don't know if
GarageBand is capable of this but it
probably okay it's getting pretty
desperate these days roll with me on
they get pretty Pro and they don't know
what you're doing but you you put
headphones into the computer so that and
then you're sending that the sound you
know like a dumb person you put
headphones into the computer there what
does that mean you you attach your
earbuds to the to the external apps jack
of the computer okay to the laptop and
then you set it up so that you're
running you're all the sounds of the
room through the laptop and through the
audio software
and then you break out the filter that
isolates certain frequencies and you
turn in ProTools man yeah well I think
you go I haven't worked in garage man in
a couple years I don't know if it's
capable of this but you have to go Pro
Tools or no logic can do it okay you get
a copy my free current frequency
isolation filter and there may be an
iPhone app at this point or just a phone
app at this point that can do this now
the problem is you say you you you let
the nose whistle start and you move the
isolation the frequency back and forth
and so you nail it and then it's gone
now Rhett knows this because in all of
our years of editing all of our internet
videos I don't know what the how we came
up with this delineation but I was like
much more of the editor like cutting
style and details but then when it came
to like an audio pass I would pass it
off to you and because that was more of
a figure out a new thing that then
applied to fixing certain problems like
this like oh there's a hum in this
particular shot the shot before and
after it don't have it so it's very
distracting in the middle of say dialog
and you could you could use these
filters and find it so you're saying
applied that particular thing you know
the downside is you have to listen to
everything through a left so that's you
know you got to carry this laptop with
you because it's live or it's like your
live recording you're working fine
sound processing that is isolating that
frequency well it's what happens in
noise cancelling headphones dynamically
but it doesn't doing it manually this
could be an awkward setup otherwise
here's another potential solution that
may be simpler punch them every time
they start doing it like when your
spouse snores I don't mean like punch
them hard I mean nudge nudge that
person's not asleep they're like what
everything let's just assume that it I
say just go up to them and before they
know it you've grabbed their nostrils
you can't know that nothing no physical
contact it gotta be passive about this
how about this this might be a better
idea I doubt that its anatomical I'm
guessing that it is a recurrent sinus
infection of some kind or this person
just has certain shaped boogers and it
just it just works itself out right okay
and so it's a recurrent thing that's not
all the time
so we're talking about a nasal issue you
need to get one of those oil diffusers
that you've got at your house yeah and
you put in some sort of decongest
congest they've got oils for everything
we got one at home that says digestion
I'm going really don't give him the
digestion giving this a conscious to
smell something and it's gonna help me
digest but I'm totally there are you
know decongestant I like the smells and
so you could you put any really pumping
you might take get four or five of these
things and this person may say why do
you have so many oil diffusers in our
office now it's like I'm just trying to
liven the place up and you keep adding
an oil diffuser every single day until
the nose whistle goes away until you get
to like twenty at which point it would
be excessive and then you do the other
thing I'll talk about with a laptop
because if you were to go the direct
route which we often recommend have the
awkward conversation well if it's
anatomical and I do believe that it is
what's the person gonna do that's like
saying you know that mole on your chin
is really annoying me can you have it
removed
well the mole doesn't make a constant
noise I know but it still is kind of the
same things like can you go to see an
ENT and get him to ream out your nostril
so that I may be the Breathe strips like
for snoring speaking of snoring maybe
they were work maybe I bet it would work
every morning you could come but how are
you you look so great and you just touch
them on the nose and you now you're
doing the touch that's when you know but
I'm doing a gentle touching I'm
congratulating you got to touch
somewhere else touch the shoulder and be
like you like it you know it like this
you look so great and you you that's
when you attach it you touch it just to
put a sticker on their nose and I did
not consent do you touch in mine my nose
bridge your fingertips are so sweaty no
that's not sweaty it's oil
oh really it's like from the diffuser
you just diffuse to my let my nose
bridge my hands are hot man I got high
smells I can't smell it it doesn't stink
they're not sweaty they're just it's
gonna help with my digestion or hot
okay that's ludicrous are you telling me
that you're gonna I gave three different
options just pick one and deal with it
but you could give them nasal strips as
a Secret Santa
you got to apply them with your hands
though secrets and is a good idea
time of year but then he just thinks
he's snoring there's a note from Santa
I heard you snore no it's not about
snoring you ever notice what's a bra
yeah or you could tell you are you gonna
start recording it and then loop it into
like a track create a new beat with it I
don't think we have helps at least one
person we went down and somebody got
helped and I'm sure you know I mean some
people probably got misguided advice but
again I did the disclaimer at the
beginning the light falling should have
been a sign for us not to continue it
wasn't it was fate for us not to give
advice tonight we pressed on and now
we're gonna reap we're gonna reap what
we've sown and here you are with us and
you know what we'll speak more at you
next week come on back tell your friends
bring them over if you dare I'm curious
how you would describe your biscuits let
us know let us know describe your
biscuits in the in US in an online short
social commentary with hash tag ear
biscuits legitimately would like to know
how you just you would describe the show
of you are gonna recommend it to someone
yeah so please let us know well we'll
look into that we'll be interested in
hash tag your biscuits and thank you
[Music]